when i was running for president um my
great fear was that
you'd get to washington and not be able
to get anything done so i was looking
for structural changes you could make
that would actually enable you to get
something done
because the dark thing is that the folks
in washington in my mind are not really
getting rewarded for getting things done
anymore
they're getting rewarded for accruing
resources making the moat
nice and deep and wide so no one can
challenge them
and avoiding any headline making scandal
like that those seem to be like the main
incentives and if you do those things
then
you'll be fine you'll get to stay in dc
and what happens to
the people is not actually tied to your
feet
so i was looking for ways that we could
change that up
uh one thing i'm passionate about which
i'd imagine it's a little further
afield but it goes back to the media
element is that i was
staggered by the lack of measurement
and discipline around the conversation
we're having about various things where
you say
hey is this working is this good is this
not good uh and then it's literally just
an argument
it's like like this was great no it's
terrible
and you're like okay like what happened
there you know it's like that you
you just look around and be and be like
well is it working
you know like to to me some of the the
things that
got me to run were the fact that like uh
we're spending twice as much as on our
health care the worst results in other
countries well that doesn't seem to be
like very
effective or our life expectancy is
declining or drug overdoses have surged
to record levels or
you know like things that objectively
you look at and say well these are not
signs of a healthy society
they're all of these things around
democracy reform too my great fear
lawrence is that the parties and this is
a guy an author named philip howard said
this
is that the parties will just play you
lose i lose you lose i lose over and
over again
while like our towns sink into the
ground
like the feedback mechanism between our
lives
and our leaders uh fortunes
like that the link has been severed and
so now it doesn't matter
and then more and more people as their
lives disintegrate will then
give up hope not vote not participate
not donate twenty dollars uh because
they just don't believe that the systems
uh systems designed to care about them
and they're right i mean you know there
there is an important
powerful group in america who benefit if
the government does nothing
and they want the government to do
nothing and the easiest thing to get in
washington
is to stop the government from doing
something so
doing nothing is extraordinarily
profitable to a huge class
of lobbyists and people in the private
sector
and they win because we've built you
know already we inherited
a constitutional design with checks and
balances that made it extremely hard to
get anything done
um francis fukuyama's work about the
vitocracy which is what we've got right
now where
so simple to veto any substantive change
means that we basically are you know
stalemated we can't do anything and so
for stalemated
there's no climate change legislation
the um health care industry can continue
to charge whatever it wants for whatever
it serves pharmaceuticals get to do
whatever they want there's no
all of these public goods that we need
some way to address we can't adjust
can you anything big tech yeah um and
all of that
is not accidental it's because we've
they've allowed the system we've allowed
the system to become one where
if you're powerful you can always block
something
and so what we need is a system where
that's no longer true
and one way to make that happen is to
cut this
cut the incentive connection by making
it so
congressmen are not worried about what
you know the jeff bezos equivalents or
want they're worried about what their
ordinary citizens want so if they go
home
and their citizens say you know where is
the health care that's affordable
um and they know that that's what
matters to them raising money and
getting elected then they'll be
responsive to it it's not
it's not rocket science it's about
getting the right incentives into the
system
everyone has negative power you're right
lawrence
like that and and our system is designed
for inertia
a congressman came to me or i came to
him
and he said to me when he arrived in dc
he said
it's like the marble columns are there
to remind you that nothing will change
[Laughter]
so we have this unfortunate kind of
mini drama like rising and falling while
nothing fundamental
gets fixed and nothing fundamental
changes and there are extraordinarily
wealthy and powerful corporations that
just benefit from nothing
big changing yeah um yeah and
and yet we find a way to get ourselves
worked up and angry about
every kind of issue without focusing on
the fact that
there's no capacity to basically steer
you know the ship
um so you know we're arguing on the deck
about like you know what we're eating
for dinner
without thinking about the fact that
still we can't steer the ship and the
ship is eventually you know gonna
run aground and you know this year 2020
has been as close to running in the
ground as i could have imagined
um you know uh and you know i just read
an article about europeans looking at
the united states and saying
you know as we imagine 300 000 americans
dying
from this uh pandemic the huge
proportion of which
caused by our own governmental
ineptitude
um and this article was about europeans
looking at us saying we just can't
believe it like
like isn't is there no recognition of
the
cost in humanity like humanity forward
for god's sake right
um you know that uh the the absolute
human costs that have been
uh suffered because of this in
ineptitude and
and a willingness to do something about
it yet here we are
still wondering whether this man will be
re-elected or whether
you know uh you know the election will
be so marred with
um corruption and ineptitude that um he
has a capacity to stay in power even
though
i can't believe the majority of
americans would want this man to be
their president
it's a heartbreaking devastating time
i'm sure people around the world are
looking
at america in disbelief and for me i
have family members who left this
country to go
to other places that had managed kovid
better where they can
live normal lives and their you know
friends who are in other
countries who aren't coming back one i
think is they might not be allowed to
come back but two they're like hey my
kids can walk around outside here in a
way that
you know like or we can go to
restaurants more appropriately because
we can go outside yeah
um it's it's a tragic
terrible time and when you talk about no
one steering a ship
run aground i mean this is it you know
like we we have we have taken the ship
and
crashed into shore and hundreds of
thousands are dying
millions tens of millions will be out of
work that we can't agree on cash relief
the the only hope i have is that the
pendulum will swing
dramatically when we're in position to
try and rebuild the country
certainly your ideas are so core and key
you definitely
moved democracy reform um up
for me from wherever it was to something
like
uh 1a or 2 or after universe basic
income because obviously i'm like this
guy you and i could alternate but the
the thing that i love
is that you ran on your heart and your
values
in 2015 2016 and then if everything goes
well like you may get
a lot of your vision accomplished uh
five years later
you know if hr one passes and i ran on
universal basic income and hopefully
will not take five years for us to pass
out
because i don't think we have five years
i might have thought we had five years
uh a number of months ago but now we
don't have five
weeks i mean you know we need to to make
big moves
well i think we should recognize our
party is going to be tested
you know i think there's a really good
chance that we
take control of congress and the
presidency and then we'll see
who our party really is because one part
of the party the part that i want to
believe in
is the reformer part the part that says
ideas like ubi
um ideas like fundamental democracy
reform is what the party stands for
let's do it let's just make it happen
and they say it will happen but there's
another part of the party
that i think is still stuck in the old
ways and they say well
public funding for campaigns you know
who knows whether that will really work
let's just you know
have more transparency or like tiny
little tittles on the corners of nothing
um and i really fear that uh if we take
over
and the democrats don't go through with
these fundamental reforms
then we really will be in a catastrophe
so it's bad enough
right now given the disaster for the
president and the control of the senate
that we don't have these changes
but if we actually gain control of
congress and they don't deliver then
then i think it's time to talk about the
next stage and this
revolution because obviously the
ordinary
democratic process has not worked i
agree
there is a need and a challenge for the
democratic party to go big
and solve some of these meaningful
structural problems
so that americans can see that they're
not just crouching there
and making some window dressing marginal
actions and they they don't recognize it
i i fear
because some of them have been there for
a long time and their lives are very
very
disconnected uh from the lives of most
everyday americans at this point
but that they need to rise to the
challenge in a very very big way
we need to if you include the the two of
us like
we're the reform element uh
the democratic party hopefully is the
vessel for that reform
but if it is not oh my gosh will there
end up being
like a whole massive
uh collision uh
it's it's it hopefully that need
is clear to them yeah
because if they don't deliver i mean
then we're gonna have to have another
podcast and talk about what the next
structure is
because it's not going to be this party
i agree with you lawrence let's put a
pin in that
we'll check back in a little while and
see whether hr one's passed
whether uh the party's rising the
challenge
um but this conversation has been
awesome and edifying i learned so much
from you
uh and your ideas are vital to the
future of our country
we need to make them a reality as soon
as possible
and i appreciate your patriotism and
service by stepping
up five years ago and helping show me
and many others the light seriously like
i donated i was like this guy is
uh a genius and correct and he's
highlighting something that most of us
are not thinking enough about
i appreciate it andrew and thank you so
much for running you were such an
inspiration to so many great people
and you brought them back you brought
them into politics and that was the most
important contribution you could make
oh thank you it means so much to me were
your kids yangyang was that
yeah yeah yeah that's yes
that's all i wanted my my oldest was a
little surprised that i knew andrew yang
i told him and he said no
come on you don't know andrew yeah he
said yeah
i feel grateful to know you and i'll
continue to
pick your brain and learn from you every
step of the way great me too
great to talk to you andrew you too be
well lawrence all the best of the family
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]